hey what's up guys welcome to another
episode of get close i am your co-host
gio and i'm bk troublemaker
bk trouble is that is that the is that
the name now no um in
in uh
junior high in high school my best
friend used to call me bk troublemaker
that's awesome because i got sent to the
office literally like every day and is
that awesome is that awesome i feel like
that's a great hype man of a friend you
know
yeah like i would do something and i
don't even know what i'm doing i'm just
being myself but apparently it wasn't
approved in the academic world and i
would just do something and the teachers
like go to the principal's office and
then my friend sitting next to me like
bk troublemaker strikes again
that's [ __ ] cool shout outs to sally
okay if you didn't already pick up on it
our friend mari is back thank you so
much for being back and you weren't
scared off after the first [ __ ]
really deep uh dive we took into your
life we like held nothing out there we
went to the swamp yeah like dude it was
a heavy
heavy conversation if you haven't heard
it yet please listen to the first
episode uh that we have marianne because
it's really [ __ ] rad
um but today we're just gonna take it
easy we're just gonna have a good time
i'm gonna ask you guys both of you guys
really stupid questions me too yeah why
not hell yeah wait you're not answering
these sure i'll jump in is this me and
bk troublemaker
do you have any nicknames you have a ton
i saw you have a ton um i don't think
there's a lot that's stick though oh all
right no spaghetti yeah no no no
spaghetti sticking people yeah people
have called me stuff like out of like
episodes that they have seen i see okay
mine is usually [ __ ]
[Laughter]
i'm going to jump right into it we'll go
i'll just kind of jump around
um all right
what's the both of you what's the
weirdest smell you have ever smelled oh
no i hate this answer why because it's
taking you back there oh yeah yeah i
know i have a terrible answer do you go
for it no that's crazy you don't even
have to think about it i know no you
have to say it it took like it
immediately [ __ ] transported her back
to that time i gotta know now
i don't know if i've ever talked about
this um okay so
when i was like maybe like in third
grade i had a really bad cold and so i
was like sick in bed for a few days or
whatnot didn't go to school that whole
rad thing but i had a
phlegm cup
what oh so i would just sit in bed and i
would just
flem into the same cup right oh my god
why not a trash can girlfriend because
i'm in third grade and i'm sick okay
fair enough i like it fair enough so i
was thinking like you're 13 and like you
can ration yeah no i got it
i was young i was young so i had a
phlegm cup right and so then like by by
by the end of it it was just like i
don't know probably like
probably an inch thick it probably had
an inch of phlegm in it what color was
it it was like green it was like green
some moments of like okay but like the
real thick ones you know like the ones
where you were just like oh is that part
of brain or was that part of like
my stomach is it like slightly crusty
still um well i crusted over right so
like i i'm like legit
irresponsible kid and so i i probably
left it for i don't know a few days or
whatnot
i just remember
like like picking it up and being like
oh yeah knowing what it is and just
being like no no
and i'm like oh my god that
actually i just got nauseous thinking
about it
but what did it smell like did you crack
the top layer like cream the way first
oh my god it would still be juicy
underneath yeah [ __ ]
did you do that
no it put me on my ass like it smelled
like
human bile just like
like cadaver like if you if you if you
broke open a coffin and you maybe tore
off a leg and you just
put that
up to your nostrils i mean it smelled
like
a human body trying to excrete itself of
the wrong things that's inside of it
just smelling like oh god just throw the
cup i mean i was just i was i think
there was a layer of shame because i
knew it came from my body yeah there was
there was a layer of guilt knowing that
i would have to carry this with me for
the rest of my life and possibly talk
about it as a full-blown adult on a
podcast yeah yeah um yeah no there were
[Music]
i don't care to share anything there's
nothing i have that will top that
do you have anything um
i have to do something kind of
interesting
but it doesn't top that
so i think most people have probably
smelled like
their their butthole yes their ear holes
whatever right absolutely um mari don't
leave me here by myself absolutely right
yes okay ear holes i was just thinking
when you said ear holes i'm just like
yeah that is such a distinct smell yeah
and it's got to be different from person
to person some people are crusty because
i've had like people are like big like
yeah he has dried like a boba boba
sized earwax that i flushed out of my
earbuds and he wants to show me this
[ __ ] no it's not and i smelled it and
i'm like kind of cool whoa it's like it
smells like it's a thousand years old
you found an ancient relic in there yeah
a fossil whoa i i that's pretty cool i
say it's cool because i have the wet
kind and so it doesn't really like ball
up ever you know there's there isn't a
substantial thing where i can hold in my
in my hand and be like i made that but
like if you can you know hang out
since you have wet um earwax have you
ever accidentally tasted your earaches
oh what the hell
i think yeah i think i tasted it oh
that's disgusting it's it's sharp yeah
it's like um it's like really bitter
i mean not on purpose maybe i did one of
these things and maybe i just went to my
mouth what do you mean oh you just
[ __ ] talked about boba out of your
ear you don't get to judge me i didn't
taste it i didn't say you did how old
were you when you when you when you
found it 30 [ __ ] 535 yeah if you were
like 11. that's true i definitely tasted
it when i was a kid on purpose it was
not on it was not an accident i was like
yeah i made that
my but mine wasn't even mine's not even
about the uh earwax it's um oh you just
wanted to share how nasty your body is
yeah like every night no every now and
then i'll go through these like
like cat
[ __ ] hairball hacking faces i'm like
like that right and then i'll feel like
this little thing come up and i'll look
at it and it's like a speck of white
have you guys seen it yes oh i know what
you're talking about that's what is that
file i don't know oh no i know what it
is i googled it it's called tonsil
stones or something like that
so it's like all your saliva that gets
packed into your tonsils if you still
have them and it gets like just
compressed compressed into a little rock
right yep and i'm like and i'm like
what's this so i put it into my hand and
i'm like what did i eat
yeah like what the [ __ ] is this
oh i could smell it and i go like this
and i'm like i can't smell it dude
it looks like a little grain of rice
it's not though
it smells like like early morning breath
times seven thousand billion yeah
yeah tonsil stone and i you could smash
it and you can smell it it gets worse if
you smash yeah and you're like
wow
well you know i'm really glad we're
talking about this because this is a
particular part of my shame that i have
never really come to terms of wanting to
google
google search yeah you just didn't want
to think it was real yeah cause if you
google it then now it's really hard what
do you google search to find the answer
i think i just google like white speck
smells like [ __ ] or something
and everyone has a picture there's
pictures
there's people that like oh you know you
can get one of those um
what's that like water flat like a water
pill a water pig they're like oh if you
go to the dentist you can tell them like
blast your throat or like i don't know
there's like people that oh that's
actually crazy look at the beehive in
there
are there a lot of them i don't know
i don't know oh my god
but i also feel bad i feel like if i go
to the dentist i don't want to get
judged and be like hey you know like
like blast me i'm sure they see
tonsil stones yeah
guys i gotta move on this [ __ ] is nasty
i would i was gonna share that story too
of my own you have those two we all do
oh she knew exactly what we were talking
about i thought it was just me no oh you
feel sad well could you say i got bad
breath so i'm like oh it's probably my
tonsil stone
oh my gosh the whole wall of them oh my
god
no
okay i gotta move on glad we all share
snow
okay well let's let's kind of within the
realm but not so much what's the most
ridiculous fact you know
hmm
since you guys went first
um i'll i'll set this one off i just
learned about it okay so um when you're
wearing earbuds or like earphones and
you're putting it in your ear hole the
bacteria in there multiplies by like 700
within an hour
what i know why i didn't look that
deeply into it but i was like what the
[ __ ] are you introducing the bacteria
from what's on your earbud uh i don't
know maybe because you're just like
sealing it in there that it's just
[ __ ] going crazy and it's just
multiplying and growing
they need to put a surgeon's general
warning on [ __ ] ear yeah like don't
keep them in there for a long time wow
yeah sorry
there's always side effects to
everything you just don't know about
them i think that we're probably pretty
gross anyway though
i think we're just like petri dishes
walking around like there's probably
bacteria all over our faces right now
absolutely have you heard of the little
spider that lives on your eyelashes you
know what the [ __ ] yeah
there's a little [ __ ]
spider that like just kind of kicks it
on your eyelashes i heard what all the
time where does it come from yeah i wash
my face and we wear mascara right so i'm
like do we do girls not have it that
much because we're like constantly
brushing yeah we're just thrilling we're
brushing it off and putting it into the
tube
what if i swim every day or something i
don't know i'm this i know i'm not like
looking into the spiders how to swim it
scares the [ __ ] out of me so i try to
pretend i didn't just hear or learn
about it
i don't know any uh
well because i know the facts so i don't
know if they're weird you know
for example give it to me we'll tell you
if it's like i don't know like i follow
a page called like science or something
or like science facts
and a lot of them they'll say did you
know blah blah blah blah blah
oh yeah i know that i'm trying to get to
the blah blah blah i don't know like
like a sea horse it can choose its
gender almost you know like depending on
like if there's more males then it'll
become a female if there's more females
becoming a male
and males can carry babies right they
better i forgot about that part no they
don't yeah i think too i think i'm like
oh yeah that's that's cool i know i knew
that
so i don't know i don't i don't know
imagine if we lived in a world where
we'd be like hey like transfer it like
mid-term you'd be like hey can you take
the baby for i don't know i've lived
with bart for
13 years now that just seeing how he
lives his life i don't think
i could be in
absolute
the worst pain ever and i don't think i
could ever give him the kid
but the
the thing is like the days that i spend
with our kid
um nothing bad happens yet until i tell
you what we've been doing and then
you're like holy [ __ ] so it still
survives it's just not the way that you
like it you trust your husband with
carrying your
child
yes
oh he's a he's a meticulous he's way
more meticulous than i am oh i think i
would trust him more than i would trust
myself really
yeah i'm more meticulous than you too
no way dude yes way jose no way dude you
have boba coming out of your ears that's
horrible
i'm meticulous enough to take it out
yours are still in there no i mean i
don't even allow it to grow that big how
do you stop it from growing i clean my
[ __ ] ears dude with what q-tip i know
you're not supposed to right i do i do
but i do i can't not do it i feel like
it's just like there's water
in my ear you've just never been to the
depths of the ocean where you've been
able to compact it into a ball
we're not allowed we're not able to
compact it into a ball we have we have
wet material yeah let's see ourselves an
ocean yours is a stone
yeah weirdo all right no other facts we
got nothing else all right um what is
something that everyone looks stupid
doing
oh
i mean
i think pooping is like definitely up
there but i feel like that's a really
basic pooping pooping outdoors pooping
outdoors yeah if you poop without a
toilet vulnerable yeah the most
vulnerable yeah you think that looks
stupid squatting pooping outdoors and
then you call them from the back like
and then they have to like look back at
you what is something that looks stupid
that everyone does when they sleep with
their mouth open too
that's pretty stupid it's pretty stupid
but you know what when i see old people
doing it i'm like ah that just looks
like it feels so good i'm like i i'm
good on you that's why does that make
sense
throat looks dry or it's going to be dry
later that's true yeah like when you go
some sleep apnea right there yeah when
you walk back on the aisle of an
airplane and then there's people that
are like that's me you're like
but now that we can be masked up i can
cover it oh yeah because i can't not
sleep on an airplane without my head my
my mouth open i think that's everybody
really yeah i think we all do it
i've seen some immaculate looking
sleepers like
no
they're just pretending yeah that's not
pretending to sleep like a princess
[Laughter]
i don't know sometimes i see people
sleeping i'm like that's a really nice
only 12 more hours
um no when i when i sleep on the i
[ __ ] hate sleeping on the plane
because i don't know if it's like my
body is shaped weird or something
but i always end up going like this and
my tongue gets swollen what and i don't
know why my body does it but it's just
so stupid as soon as it gets swollen
i bite it
what so there'll be times i'm sleeping
i'm sleeping like this right
i think like my tongue gets swollen and
i go like ow why the [ __ ] did i do that
and i'll try to go back to sleep and
then
i fight again
and it hurts that's like the equivalency
of like pinching yourself to make sure
you're dreaming
like yeah i'm like why the [ __ ] do i
keep doing this wait you pinch yourself
in your dreams no it's like that's
that's the thing that they say right oh
okay
like paint yourself in your dream okay
yeah
i'm like i wanted to hear that huh i
keep biting and it hurts i don't like
that yeah you need like a tongue guard
or something or i just need to like be
able to get business class like every
time yeah boy normal person i just want
like a like head gear to keep my neck
here rather than doing the the yeah
because oh my gosh i can my i have i
have a neck that is just too loose that
i can just slump over so badly oh from
the flexibility of ballet probably
that's not looking at my phone just like
like i mean
i'll just like whoa whoa she can make
her head like parallel
yeah
it doesn't feel good that's that's for
sure but it's like i just want like a
like headgear to keep it like this then
i can be like one of those you know i
wish the scary looking [ __ ] people
and then i'll sleep like this and
they're like oh look at that [ __ ]
vampire on here yeah that's [ __ ]
scary i wish like the airplane seats had
a headband oh yeah just keep your head
around there yes
[Laughter]
my tongue won't stick out i don't have
to bite it i'd be into that just keeps
moving everyone looks so sweet
yes
everyone looks so stupid
okay um
that's [ __ ] funny um okay maybe you
you'll have more of these i don't have
that many but what's the best wi-fi name
you've seen or maybe you might even have
one uh uh ours right now is y fighter
and i don't think that's very good
um
uh
what's the best one
you haven't seen any ours right now is
boom shock a lot that's not even that
crazy it's something our son says
when we're on jk news we're talking
about like what would be a wi-fi name
where people wouldn't want to try to
steal a logon and it was uh like i like
kids
that's a good one like oh [ __ ]
that's a great oh maybe you don't want
to i'm a racist
yeah that one's a good one too yeah i
don't want that tied to my eye i kind of
feel pressure anytime like i've had to
order new wi-fi or whatever that i feel
like i want something funny to be on
there so that when someone is trying to
log on they see mine and i make their
day yeah i feel this pressure i really
do i do too you do too yeah are you ours
used to be nacho wi-fi and i was like oh
that's funny but that's like a very like
2015 yeah yeah it's pretty good though
humor back then was really easy yeah
yeah or if you go in your neighborhood
and you set up your wi-fi and you see
everyone else's you're like
man a lot of people are boring it's just
my spectrum three five seven nine
whatever oh yeah like eight people you
judge them yeah yeah you judge them like
crazy okay i'm gonna judge your ass
really [ __ ] hard right now so pick
the right one oh [ __ ]
it's toilet paper over under there's
only one choice
just off the roll so that you just you
can do this and muffle it just kidding
no no no it's it's over thank you
thank you are there people who who say
the other way is my mom
really she does under so she still folds
the arrow and underneath just dangling
like that i get there's no folding
happening but she does it so it's funny
because uh when i first had taika
she she babysat for us she would come
every single day and she would help me
raise this child
um so with that she's still a mom so
she's like picking up after
us or or my son and stuff and you know
she would refill the toilet paper or
sweep or do whatever and i was
constantly changing the toilet paper
from under to over it was always a
[ __ ] battle and i always thought it
was him or i thought it was other people
just kind of refilling the toilet the
toilet roll yeah and then i go to her
house and all of them are under i'm like
that [ __ ] raised me weird that's why i
never liked her
because of the toilet paper situation
that's the only reason
no i i can understand people being
haphazard and being like i don't really
think about it or care i think about
other people but to do it intentionally
is a that is a
what else does she do is becomes the
question right you know my mom does it
under two why i don't know i didn't see
the blueprints of how it was invented
no but when i started going to when i
started going to hotels as a kid
and then i saw that it was over i'm like
okay
if the hospitality industry says it's
over
then it's over that is so [ __ ]
logical that's the best argument i've
heard that's what i mean i always aim
for like okay what's supposed to be
the example for everyone to follow you
know what does a butler do what would
alfred do yeah in the batman universe he
has batman's under no way no way
that is the best argument ever
all right internet you guys could stop
now we already know how the toilet paper
should happen yeah go to the wind and
see if it's over under
i'll do it that way imagine they would
just do everything under just to like
infuriate people and they'll just i feel
like that would be like a
an onion headline
that would be good or they should do it
for like april fools yeah like when you
check in it's all fun
that's funny or if like the you check
into the hotel and instead of the top
part being folded over it's like the
bottom that's folded over and you're
like what the [ __ ] yeah
now that's what i'm going to do every
time i go to a hotel room i'm going to
just switch it on purpose [ __ ] people up
okay
since we're so into logic here um how
many chickens would it take to kill an
elephant
this is a [ __ ] riddle
no
oh if chickens have coveted
we could probably play with that
elephant we also have to assume that the
elephant can't fight back right because
all the elephant has to do just [ __ ]
stomp on it yeah or just do that yeah so
nose in this question i'm assuming the
elephant cannot move
how many chickens would it take yeah i
don't think a chicken would have it in
its
it's like
natural quality to want to kill the
elephant okay i know it's not a chicken
but have you ever
uh dealt with a rooster before
yeah but i feel like that's when a
rooster feels threatened i didn't do
anything to this rooster at all dude
okay i know i have that personality but
i promise you okay so this is what
happened um my sister had just moved
into she bought a house
and it had this beautiful backyard and
in this backyard it was like this
awesome garden in this garden i guess
the house was vacant for so long that
like birds started just kind of like uh
inhabiting it and she was like oh how
cute like i'm gonna have a bird as a pet
so she kept one of the chicks because
there were chicks now at this point um
this chick grew up and it and she's like
oh i think it's a chicken actually and
it like hit puberty or whatever and it
became a rooster
so we're like oh [ __ ] okay well my dad's
like dude a rooster yeah let's bring in
our house we have this [ __ ] rooster
and one day
um it was just my mom has her garden it
has like this cute little fence on it
and it's just kind of like bouncing on
it and i go outside um i think to go i
forgot what i went to do we make eye
contact you know chicken set or like we
just have it on the side of the head
it like looks at me and i'm like bro
i'm just trying to do my thing like you
just chill on your little wire and you
see it's tail trying to balance itself
and it just charged at me for no [ __ ]
reason and i was like okay what's it i
mean it's a bird like how
how like threatening is this thing going
to be so it charges at me and i try to
like stomp my feet to scare it because
i'm obviously bigger than it and it
would still like puff in its chest and
it like it got really massive and i'm
like all right well [ __ ] this guy's
really aggressive so i got like a rug or
something that was or like a towel or
some [ __ ] and i started like kind of
whipping it to be like dude i'm about to
[ __ ] you up and it got even more angry
and i started pecking at my
ended up having to kick this [ __ ]
bird and i love animals so i was like
crying as i'm trying to kick this bird
off of me i ended up having to sprint
away dude were you bleeding
no because i was moving i was [ __ ]
bobbing and
oh
weaving
god
so
birds take that comment back birds can
be
very vicious i remember i have a
distinct memory of being a kid and like
um giving bread to like some like swans
and then like a pack of geese surrounded
me they're aggressive too yeah and i
just remember crying and then they're
just pecking at me trying to get to my
bread damn [ __ ] haters no they're
trying to murder you those partners
that's what's really happening
with that said though i don't think that
they would peck it
at an elephant
i think you're right it was a stupid
question who submitted this what's the
answer do you have the answer no no
these are just hypotheticals oh no
no no nikki troublemaker wants a
scientific answer he wants the real he
wants the real number of chickens
scientifically it's just it's physically
impossible
that's what i've been trying to say okay
fine all right which body part do you
wish you could detach and why
detach yeah [ __ ] the penis why do you
want to detach it because sometimes
you're climbing a tree and gets scraped
on oh i would want to get my boobs off
you just go
yeah really yeah why
um
so even before i had implants i just
always had like sensitive boobs so like
if i'm wrestling and doing whatever like
it would hurt i don't know if does it
hurt on guys no right because you just
have no it just feels like like like
another muscle no i didn't feel that so
it would hurt so i wish i could just
take them off and then imagine not
wearing a bra yeah
i don't have much to take off i think i
would take my head off
still be alive well yeah of course what
do you have this question already defies
[ __ ] all physics dudes yeah do you
take your penis off i can take my head
off yeah what's up with the head i want
to do my makeup oh that is oh [ __ ] i
can't see
oh right well maybe i can do my hair
oh that's cool you can see what it looks
like from the back
yeah
and you can look at your entire body now
yeah and like place it on its side it's
like what does my butthole really look
like oh my god yeah i walk away
honestly like what do people see from
behind and then you're like walking
that'd be so sick because then you could
be like what's that and you take off
your head and just roll it over there
but then you can't get it back or does
it have like little legs oh hopefully
maybe you need like a you need like a
bungee cord or something
dude imagine all the jealous [ __ ]
significant others just rolling their
heads around we're gonna leave their
head everywhere yeah and you just see
your girlfriend's head down there what
are you doing over here yeah
like those memes i bet he's cheating on
me but they're like playing games or
whatever oh that's a good one if you
detach your head though
and like let's say
it's like drinking water does the water
go back to your body or it just spills
out oh i don't ruin the magic i'm not
into it i think i think it just has like
a magical portal so it goes right into
you
yeah oh that's tight yeah it just kind
of like
it just finds where it's supposed to go
because i would that'd be sick where you
could roll your head at someone and then
you throw up on them
oh
this way too
dude i like the head one i hope somebody
asks me this question further down the
line
i'm gonna steal your answer i'm just
letting you know i
yeah
yeah it's that or the boobs it would be
great to be able to have like different
sets of boobs oh you know because like
running boobs are different from like
the evening gown boob oh yeah you know
so it's like if you could just like
detach them for like your needs that
would be very very cool well if you ever
invent any of that i'll be your next
vegetable boobies
i wish i had different penis sizes too
why well you have you want to have the
the evening gown equivalent for a dude
would be like speedos
right you want to look like you're
hiding like a russet potato or something
oh but that's like a nice little yam
yeah like a nice little yam but then if
you're uh running
then you kind of don't want anything you
don't want anything bouncing around yeah
i i always i do think about that a lot
about dudes
dangling it just seems really um
inconvenient and just kind of like it's
just out there yeah just dangling around
the gray sweats man whenever they wear
grey sweats and they're [ __ ] running
track and field or whatever i'm like bro
you should just pick the better
underwear because the other animals
right they're kind of away until they
need it like you know like a dog or a
horse then it comes out yeah retract
yeah kind of it's just like it's like
the missiles are like
versus the irresponsible human being
it's just the missiles are just kind of
like
you're like is that thing going to
explode at any time you don't know yeah
that's a good one yeah we need the
compact size yeah speaking of um
creatures what mythical creature would
improve uh the world if it existed oh
man
i feel like we would [ __ ] pervert
anything that we would have that's
mythical you know what i mean like what
do you mean like i i feel like if if
it's something that it's like a fire
breathing like dragon we would just pump
the [ __ ] out of that thing to like work
for our industries like it would be
fueling
like the
real the
corporate industries and it would just
be dragons just like
you know what a [ __ ] dragon imagine
that you're driving down the 215 and
there's like a [ __ ] dragon flying
over here
referencing the vegas that's the thing
they wouldn't be beautiful and free and
flying around we would find a way to to
make them fit into the corporate machine
all right guys
all right damn can we just did you see
cora you know all those people with
those
everyone's got their you know their
different elements and powers and what
are they doing they're going to a nine
to five to work
their jobs with their awesome powers
okay fine fine i'm gonna flip it i'm
gonna flip it then because i agree we do
[ __ ] everything up
we don't that's why we can't have nice
things i get it okay we all possess our
own mythical creature oh [ __ ] so we're
in charge of it yes there is evil out
there and they're going to use theirs
for better like we found like we found
our own mythical pet in the forest that
no one knows about what did we do with
it yeah and i mean now everyone has a
little mythical pet i'm sure there's a
movie out there like this we totally
wouldn't like
make them fight each other and keep them
in little balls
right oh man we totally wouldn't do that
for our own achievements of becoming the
ultimate trainer no we wouldn't do that
all right
that would be kind of cool um i feel
like we would do the boil down version
of the corporate and still exploit them
in our own
personal way like if we had a fire
breathing small dragon
you're like hey we gotta cook dinner get
out of it yeah if i have to like light
up my grill i'm like i'm not gonna i'm
like just you light it up little giblets
come out here
and then how cute you know i want a
unicorn or if you live in a place where
like it gets snowed in instead of
shoveling your driveway just go you go
maybe a phoenix what's the one that
[ __ ] flies is it phoenix phoenix and
dragons they both fly no but i want a
horse i'm a basic [ __ ] pegasus
sure that's true oh yeah flying horse
yeah two and one
yeah that's what i want basic [ __ ] and
i look hot i love my pegasus
you look like a [ __ ] valkyrie it
looks so dope i'm gonna get fake
hair valkyries are what norse culture
they're like yeah like i i don't think
they're all female but there's a lot of
female like valkyrie warriors oh yeah
that's what i want that's like the
[ __ ] you you would rock those legs
yes
all gold yeah i'm in
halloween yeah you should scrub my mind
get out of here all right
what about you guys
huh
kind of like minotaurs a little bit
half horse half uh
half a human yeah
that one looks weird i love minotaurs
they're so cool looking they're scary
because you could kind of like i had a
very weird sexual awakening with
gargoyles and at a moment
a few years later and i'm like i'd
i'd be into that you know who i thought
was well you thought gargoyle is a
cartoon with sexy hell yeah
who which one goliath yes dude goliath
oh my god it was pretty manly
so was the [ __ ] beast beauty and the
beast yeah yeah yeah i do i'm real good
yeah stop making those those like beast
people hot you know don't do that when
he transformed into the prince again
it's not as hot not as hot yeah i got
beast gaston and then the princess gasps
oh my god i i thought gaston was hot and
then like as an adult i was like mari
we gotta talk about some things don't
you think that this guy was
hot
yeah he had the pecs the [ __ ] hair
and he was a dick yeah but he was
terrible he was like uh
i i guess if you're against beasts then
i guess it's a form of racism
uh no he's protecting his village and
his woman because he wanted belle no
he's like he took her
he's a messiah i like well okay wait a
minute we can look at it that way or if
the i mean what if the girl likes to
feel like she's little and hopeless yeah
but belle didn't she's like i read books
and i'm independent he's like no you're
gonna be my wife and look at my big toe
that's sticking out of my sock that's
true i'm gross but those three those
triplets were all about the triplets
loved it see yeah
i would have been in tripoli i'm like oh
make me feel little
[Laughter]
i don't know what creature i would want
i i think that i would just want um
some
i want like a
like a bear like a transforming bear
like something that's like little and
then when like it's pissed off or i'm
pissed off which is like
you know what i mean
that is so rad like it's all cute and
like not menacing at all people are like
oh
and then you're like attack yeah that's
pretty cool that is [ __ ] red you have
really good answers but but i think that
that's also why i haven't um unlocked my
mythical creature because i would just
um
use it like i'd just be like that guy
cut me off [ __ ] go go get that guy
and then he'd be like craw and be like
you know i don't feel that good about it
i'm sorry your car is [ __ ] mangled
you're gonna have to go to the hospital
come on bear
come on back oh my god it's like the
most like basic [ __ ] like
yeah line kill him yeah no i i wouldn't
i wouldn't become a superhero i would
just be the same basic person just being
like now i have a [ __ ] mythical bear
[ __ ] like don't cut me off i would
still be the same terrible person oh
[ __ ] that's probably why we weren't
gifted these things yeah
[ __ ]
through wild there's a parallel universe
in which we are all a lot more
altruistic and we have all these
superpowers i [ __ ] love you because i
was thinking if i was superman
i think i would just be a construction
worker
you'd be the best i would just be like
hey you know what
that forklift or whatever those
excavator things i'm like
you don't even have to buy it
you just pay me a yearly salary of like
2 million or 5 million you want the
steel beam over there point yep and it's
over there you know are you fighting
crime anymore hell i'm trying to make
money but wait did you not watch the
incredibles
that's not superman it's not but he has
the dad's like ultimate strength okay
yeah does he have lasers out of his eyes
no but he's working a nine to five now
and he feels like he there's no purpose
he wasn't using his strength in his nine
to five though was he no he wasn't but
then when he would get pissed or
whatever he it would kind of come out
but that's what i'm saying the superman
felt wasted superman is the ultimate
construction worker because he could
weld [ __ ] with his eyes yeah he could
see through the walls and be like nope
there's there's
rot in there it's a building inspector
yeah i'm like oh man these pipes are
ruined and i could just well
why make yourself normal because you
just have everything now yeah cause i'm
the i'm the ultimate construction worker
but you don't need to make a living
anymore you can just take whatever the
[ __ ] you want no he's superman i want to
be a productive
uh citizen in society i want to
contribute yeah and i'm i'm the ultimate
i'm an inspector i can weld things i can
move things like a crane
that's the ultimate and i can fly it you
need me to fix the top of that building
i'll go right there right now all right
let's see all right
um
oh what would be the creepiest thing you
could say while passing a stranger on
the street
the creepiest yeah and you can't say
i'll kill you that's not that creepy
this reminds me of a very old dane cook
uh
joke which one he's like
he was talking about something about
being like in the airport and just like
being like don't go on the plane
like things like that like [ __ ] yeah
holy [ __ ] oh that is so good
or like i wouldn't go in there if i were
you yeah
if someone told you don't go on the
plane
what do you guys do i'm not going on the
floor you really wouldn't go like no no
it's a gamble
would you just like
call the cops yes but would you go on
the plane now he's arrested no i mean
i need to get it inspected now
yeah i don't feel comfortable damn so
you would delay a flight just because
someone told you that uh or no or like
know that i didn't get on it and allowed
everyone else to get on it and then it
[ __ ] explodes mid [ __ ] air
and now i live with this guilt for the
rest of my life yeah i'm not going to
get on it's either that or then like
nothing is there and then you become the
person
you know right like i'm never going to
see them again like the the
either way it's massive right like you
don't [ __ ] strangers
yeah i either save their life or they
hate me what's the proper conversation
that happened they go don't get on the
plane are you getting on the plane
i feel like i would just be like run
after that person be like hey like
who are you like why why like
like uh why did you tell me and not
other people oh cause uh you have a look
to you and i trust you
and i'm not gonna tell you anything else
what are you going to do what's your
name
uh john doe john doan you got i think i
i i to that person be like you gotta try
harder than that one buddy fine
stevie oh [ __ ] yeah
like do you have do you have a carry-on
well meanwhile you're letting all these
people [ __ ] get on the flight you
guys what am i supposed to do i don't
know no one trained me for these things
yeah i feel like i would just talk to
the person and then i'd be like wait do
you know what flight i'm going on
and then it hits you right yeah i'd be
like what light am i getting on you tell
me which flight am i going on
but then now you have this knowledge
that a flight
is imp potential if that person doesn't
know which flight i was going on and
they're like they're like don't get on
the flight i'd be like [ __ ] you dude you
don't know anything because you could be
at wetzel's pretzels or whatever that's
right and then you're like you don't
know my terminal's over there right
sometimes i sit at not at my gate
because my gate has too many people so i
go to an empty gate i do that so if
somebody was like don't get on that
flight it'd be like i'm not on that
flight [ __ ] and you don't tell
anybody no i mean i would just be like
what flight do you think i'm on
you know
this one
you think i'm going to albuquerque or
not
[Laughter]
all right there's creepy things you
could say
i think anything is creepy just talking
to a stranger and just injecting any
conversation
is creepy you can't even going like that
you look nice like oh don't look at me
yeah
what if they're hot then they're like
yeah what else is it creepy nope
right isn't that [ __ ] up that's pretty
[ __ ] up because if they're a fine
looking person they go oh you smell good
you'd be like i think like what do i
smell like
like what do i smell like to you to make
you say that
i'd be too inquisitive you smell good
you're like what flat are you on
yeah i'd be too inquisitive and then
their boner would just fly away like the
detachable penis yeah
okay if you were arrested with no
explanation what would your friends and
family assume you had done
oh
bk troublemaker yeah bk troublemaker
what would they think i have done yeah
what would they think i have done like
let's say i'm eating a dinner with my
parents
and then getting arrested and then these
guys in like suits or like police
officers come is it like people in suits
with like the [ __ ] curly curl things
remember that's what happened to us so
we had just started dating
uh we were probably like a month or two
in dating and um he was at a yellow
light about to turn red
and i was like oh [ __ ] just take it
so he took a red um and as he took the
left turn on that red a police car saw
it immediately pulled us over
license of registration gives them all
that stuff the cop goes back to his car
typing up some stuff cop comes back goes
sorry
he didn't say that i just have fun um he
was like uh you i'm gonna have to
uh like under arrest or what did he say
he's like you're gonna have to step out
of the vehicle
and i'm like oh sure
sure officer
and he sat me and were you sat on the
curb too no it was just you and i think
he just puts you in handcuffs and then
he started looking all over the car and
stuff
yeah put him in handcuffs takes him away
and he's like well can you tell me
what's what i'm getting arrested for and
he wouldn't tell us because he's like
it's out of my jurisdiction it just says
it in the thing that like there's a
warrant for your arrest i'll try to play
nice too because at that time it was
literally like
when we're doing jk part time we just
graduated college and so we needed to
find other jobs so i was actually
applying to multiple police departments
so i was like oh um i was like just let
you know underneath my seat i have some
police officer applications
just to kind of give a [ __ ] just to see
if i can like you know like i don't know
give some sort of he didn't really care
he's like okay that's cool sit on the
curb so he takes him away and i'm
sitting i'm going who the [ __ ] am i
dating
because that's not something you ask
right like have you ever been arrested
is there like a search i mean is there a
warrant for your right like and this was
like at like 10 or 11 at night too no it
was midday dude no it was at night
all right because you have to come and
pick me up at like 5 00 a.m yeah because
you had to stay at night exactly
yeah so it's night time yeah well that's
what happened well it ended up being
some [ __ ] expired dog tags
no
it up because i guess yeah city
databases don't cross at that time maybe
now it's different
scary
thing yeah cause i was like what in the
world i'm like i can't believe i trusted
this guy like you know we've already
been like we've been having sex like
holy crap i let him like what if he's a
murderer like
i was just like i really [ __ ] up so
how how long between that incident and
then finding out what it was for
like a day and a half because i could
stay there a night oh my god yeah so i
was like telling my girlfriend's like
dude i don't know what i should should i
break up with and you picked him up
though yeah i mean
that's a
i'm a red rider guy
it was crazy because like so it was i
got arrested in alhambra
the the
warrant code thing was for el monte
another city
and um
when i got to like the the holding cell
of the police department there i was
like oh what am i getting arrested for
and they're like what were you doing
armani like 10 years ago or whatever and
i was like
uh i don't know
and then they wouldn't they wouldn't
answer any of my questions they put me
in a cell and it was me
and and some cholo in a cell then there
was like some stripper looking chicks
that they brought in that put another
cell oh i thought they put them in the
same cell as you know what and then
there was like a like a drunk clown
looking dude i'm like is this is this
what
these are the type of people that get
arrested in the middle of the night what
the [ __ ]
and then i'll have to stay there for
like four or five hours until i guess
the police departments can clear it up
and then all it was was my dog tyson i
didn't pay his tax and then i guess it
just keeps accumulating and i
guess it's a turns into a warrant
what yeah when i found out at the end
i'm like what the [ __ ] are you kidding
me i had to pee in this metal thing
while this cholo was looking at my penis
because my dog tags were expired
it's weird that is so bananas yeah that
just seems like such a waste of uh their
time and like their
resources and they cut all my shoelaces
and the drawstring in my shorts
because it can't be used as weapons
right yeah and i'm not i'm not i don't
have an inmate uniform so they're like
i'm sorry we have to cut it so they cut
this so i can't strangle anybody and
they took the drawstring out so not to
hold on to my shorts the whole time why
did they have to cut it why don't they
just undo it you know and so you can
read the power you know how they are i
don't know my gosh yeah what are you
getting arrested for or what are your
what is your family or friends assuming
you did that's a
man i don't know
i at a different time in my life it
would have been like speeding or like
something like traffic related but now i
don't speed at all i i like
i'm i'm a good citizen behind the wheel
i don't know what it would be now i mean
either maybe fighting they'd be like no
i don't even think they would assume
that
yeah i'm a good person yeah what would
you think if i get arrested like we're
just having dinner and someone just
comes in like no i just call you hey i'm
in jail
oh
fighting probably
oh that's what you would think that's
the only thing i could think of yeah you
beat someone's ass someone starts oh
that's so cute you think i win
yeah thank you
hell yeah
i think you would definitely win i've
never been in a fight but the fact that
it was that comp yeah i feel like people
who have never been in a fight are is
because people wouldn't like initiate
that maybe people who look like they
could win a fight and who's never been
in a fight it's like yeah because people
wouldn't start it with you in the first
place i am
i am 511 so i get it they'd have to be
really confident really technically
skilled to be like yeah i can take that
yeah i can climb that [ __ ] tree
knock her down
that's probably it
so you don't know maybe speeding i don't
know now would be i i think it would be
uh
i
i don't know
okay maybe i didn't pay my taxes i was
thinking that would be something like
some like adult [ __ ] yeah some boring
you know something boring yeah didn't go
to jury duty or something yeah oh i have
jury duty coming up for the first time
in nevada actually whoa
yeah i'm kind of excited to go why i
don't know i haven't really served jury
duty for real before
check up on some nevada drama
i don't know it's gonna be interesting
maybe it's just out of coming out of the
panda making me like i get to see people
in a room
probably i get to be called on and
someone's going to be like hey what do
you think it'd be like oh you want my
opinion okay yeah let me let me where do
i start you're like we don't want her
yeah we don't want her i picture you
showing up to jury dude just high five
yep
guilty not guilty
do i livestream this can i livestream
this or what's going on here everybody
yeah that's [ __ ] funny
okay if you were transported 400 years
into the past
with no clothes or anything else
how would you prove that you're from the
future
400 yeah
couldn't i just tell them [ __ ] that's
gonna happen real soon how do you prove
it though dude like yeah you just sound
like a loon yeah but you know you know
this wait what's the math what's 400
years in the past guy
guy don't even know where we're at right
now what is it 2022 also 16 22 16 22
what was happening then let me look at
that 16 22 i would probably say one
sentence and be like you're not from
this place you are uh
like a japanese woman
if it was like in the same place if i
was a japanese woman in nevada in the
1600s i'd just [ __ ] probably die
before i said it there's like nothing
even exist okay let's pretend that's
pre-america you guys are way too [ __ ]
smart can we dumb it down i'm just
saying
women of our generation in general can't
go backwards it's been bad
all throughout okay when you add
minority on it it's really bad for all
of us we can't [ __ ] go backwards what
are you talking about we're all gonna
die you just happen to go back but in
japan now okay do you speak japanese i
do okay thank god yeah so now you're
going back okay so in the u.s at least
the jamestown massacre was popping off
oh
hey
i think there's a massacre tomorrow and
then they would happen but you're right
what is it like bro that was like two
weeks ago then what can you say you're
like yeah [ __ ] i'm like there's
probably gonna be a tea party in boston
just look out yeah you're gonna dump tea
into the ocean
damn and then you just become this all
powerful [ __ ] what are they called
like oracles oh yeah oh i feel like i
don't know enough like actual us history
to be like this is what's gonna happen
i'm like y'all know hulk hogan he's
gonna be a thing of the future
yeah
uh and then they'd be like she's saying
words we've never talked about like cell
phones yeah she's just listening yeah
we're in the [ __ ] pit of death i i
don't know enough of what's happening in
the 1600s or like about to happen
in like the government like trust me i'm
i'm gonna be holding a job and i'm gonna
have like i'm gonna be a boss
what if we start yelling things that are
gonna happen anyways and it sounds like
a good idea like
i think for thanksgiving we should just
kill a turkey and eat it and everyone's
like yeah that sounds like a good idea
you like start inventing stuff you hate
to post it yeah you just start things
that are gonna happen anyways yeah in
that time
well isn't that the point because you're
trying to prove that
then it might work
right i hope so i don't know it would
have to be such a slow role like can you
imagine being like let's talk about
racism guys i think maybe we should like
nip that in the bud
like a [ __ ] arrow yeah yeah too soon
too soon too soon what if you had like
immunity and you couldn't die in that
time so it would just be like okay we'll
try it out try it again then we'll try
it over what if you had as many tries as
you possibly could to try to
the groundhog day yeah it's like you
repeat the same thing every day oh man
i'm gonna kill myself
i'm out i wonder if we go back in time
if we would spread disease to them like
yeah we would we would totally like mr
genie can you send me back when i'm
covered positive please thank you
[Laughter]
yeah there's so many loopholes in time
travel that that just wouldn't work like
the amount of like i think we would
probably be some sort of like
uh like super vaccinated sort of thing
like we were probably carrying so many
diseases that would keel over like an
entire generation for sure it's like
back then for sure yeah they'd probably
look at us and be like whoa your teeth
are white oh yeah you have to like too
clean they'd probably pick out all of
our teeth because they're like those got
to be worth something maybe that's how
they know we're from the future me it's
like oh you have straight teeth and fake
boobs definitely good [ __ ] skin yeah
like in the future colored hair can you
imagine going there and look like purple
hair oh yeah
yeah definitely wedge all right well on
that same note um if you were wrongfully
put in a sane asylum i'm sure you guys
have heard this one how would you
convince him that you're actually sane
and not just pretending to be sane
that one is a [ __ ] one and i feel like
it's kind of [ __ ] that happens yeah
because i could catch 22 right
trust me come on give me everyone
and they're like yeah yeah prove it how
do you say that guy that guy says that
too
yeah all right that's a rough one
yeah i think i would just convince all
of the crazy people to follow me and
then we all turn on
all the [ __ ] staff and we just bounce
that's the only way or i think you just
gotta be normal
you know what i mean like all like
normal what does that mean like you just
go like hey like you know you name like
a shitty sports team
like hey the chargers kind of suck huh
like oh you're like bond
normal [ __ ] and then you're medicated
i'm medicated why but don't they give
everyone medication i love how you're
just spitting back and forth yeah well
well i that that was that was a game
changer in this whole thing right
medicare i didn't think they would be
medicated but why would you not be well
they got to know what to medicate you
for right i feel like chill i feel like
they would they would medicate you if
you were like
you know what i mean like if you're like
going insane like like with like the i
don't know do they use chains oh i hope
you don't know what they did yeah they
keep you you know restricted if you're
not fighting that then maybe they're not
going to be like oh yeah we should pump
pump that person with drugs i hope so i
don't know the protocol yeah thank god
yeah so i'm thinking like
i don't know like arkham like in gotham
right that's why there's like chains and
stuff where all the crazy like joker
scarecrow they lock all those
people up yeah so that's what i'm
thinking and you just go hey
the chargers kind of stuck huh
you know that's just anything sports
really yeah
but then what if like joker starts to
like come into the conversation totally
normal too
and then and then and then
his like normalcy gets wrapped up with
your normalcy and they're like see no
you're not normal because joker can be
normal joker's talking about the
chargers too now what do you do bk
troublemaker i don't think joker likes
to charge i don't think he's into sports
probably two above it
seems like a [ __ ] insane genius maybe
that's why he went crazy i don't know
his origin story actually i don't know
either
yeah i don't know why he went
bonkers i know he i know he fell into
like a vat of
uh acid isn't that toothpaste that's two
faces two face two
they both did i thought
that's why he's all like pale isn't he
no i thought that was makeup
that's makeup yeah
and then like his makeup i think like he
split i forgot why he split there's also
different yeah there's different jokers
there is does heath ledger and the wacky
and phoenix one the only one that
matters is the one in the [ __ ] 80s
with uh jack nicholson
that's the best one are you sure i
re-watched it
[Music]
and it was
it was really slow i actually got bored
watching it i'm like oh my gosh like
just i'm a broken person
i'm like i'm like let's cut some of this
out you know let's let's just cut out
all uh just keep saying
so much talking well wait what old movie
are you like into because all of them
are that slow they're not all that slow
which one's not um
i would say
like think of any
yeah i mean i guess they are all pretty
slow but like i think that the things
that are meant to be slow like kurosawa
stuff is like slow but it's so much
because it's like you're seeing scenes
and like the the build up of a scene is
because of like the cinematic like slow
roll of like looking at like the natural
environment around you but that's like
that's part of it but like i don't know
with batman i was just like and it's
cheesy for sure yeah it was kind of
cheesy all the fight scenes and [ __ ] the
i took this film writing class
and we were analyzing casablanca
and because the teacher
told us what to appreciate and focus on
there was just so much [ __ ] that i was
like holy [ __ ] what i thought was slow
wasn't like from the way it's framed
from the way like
how people are casting a shadow and that
is to foreshadow what's gonna happen or
how like they have the item splitting
the two characters to show that that's
what they're gonna fight later on just
like
i was like whoa i did not know black and
white movies are this deep have you seen
the lighthouse no
it's so good that's a slow like like now
what era are we talking about uh it came
out a couple years ago it's with uh
robert pattinson and willem dafoe
and i love wonderful
have you seen him in anything other than
twilight
no
have i i feel like i have and i was like
this is still [ __ ] twilight guy if
you if you just go with who you think he
is with twilight and then watch the
lighthouse okay i don't think you'll
ever be able to go in the reverse and be
like yeah that's the twilight guy
because it will [ __ ] you up he's so good
he's so good and it's not the same
person he hasn't been for the same
person but it's like that's the other
thing we're right like going back to
that other conversation we had of like
sluffing off like who you think somebody
is yeah
no matter how much work they've put in
that you haven't seen you still see them
as like the right person they were
that that is definitely the robber
patterns in effect okay i gotta watch it
the lighthouse yeah the lighthouse okay
what is the ugliest thing you own
ooh
the ugliest thing i own
probably like like the pair of like uh
like nude underwear
you know it's like why are you laughing
you have something too like that because
it's
it's a necessity item why is it
necessity so that it so that it's not
seen under certain clothing right so it
has to be this like
like ugly nude color and it's just
underwear
i think it made me laugh because she's
talking about her underwear i picture my
most ugliest tattered underwear that i
feel like i'm actually yeah i'm wearing
right now
um this is your period underwear well it
has that element to it and i think i've
worn it so much and you know like your
vag just has acids just to keep it clean
what the [ __ ] dude it just keeps it's
like it keeps it clean don't get me
wrong i like your acids but keep going
oh i mean i just feel sorry for the
underwear yeah you should see it it's
like
it's wrecked how much is under it why
don't you get some new ones right i know
dude that's that's a that's like an
everyday question right yeah like you
rifle through yeah and like you have
some nice underwear and then you just
pick the one where you're just like i
don't know i'm like i'm shamed i'm
ashamed of this right and then you put
them on right and then i'm like okay
this is the last time i'm wearing it and
then i put it in the [ __ ] hamper and
then i'm like all right well this will
be the last step and like you know it
has that layer of that cotton over it
yes um well that thing is tattered and
has holes and it's [ __ ] up and it's
not really doing anything at this point
either but here we are i'm literally
wearing them right now i don't own
anything ugly i think
excuse me name one thing what's what i
think all my shit's sick
i could it could be something on your
body
like what i don't know i don't know i'm
just throwing different you don't have a
single ugly thing his whole closet is
ugly dude
[Laughter]
no all my stuff's cool really i don't
know you telling me you don't have one
ugly sock you don't have one sock his
underwear is wrecked
his underwear has seen some [ __ ] why is
underwear expensive i [ __ ] hate like
expensive i i feel like like the like
nice underwear oh i don't know because
it should be like a dollar right
underwear because they're like lacy and
i'm like i don't want to wear this and
it doesn't look good if you're wearing
tights because now it's all that lace
[ __ ] yeah
you can only wear it if you're not
wearing anything else exactly i don't
know like la perla
what's la perla or the pearl or whatever
it's a the [ __ ] most expensive one of
the most how much are those guys let me
look it up
because underwear should be a dollar
it really is especially ours yeah barely
anything it really should be a dollar
and it's like uh i think it's why it
doesn't get replaced because you're like
i'm gonna [ __ ] money on
la perla
six hundred and fifty dollars for this
ladies
that's cool
i think it's a flex how do you even flex
if it's underneath well i mean if you
know you know those type of things where
it's like one of those like
and then everyone goes
can you tell from a bra strap that's la
pro i'd be like target i'm for sure
gonna be like you better [ __ ] put the
name oh wait where's my bro oh there's
like you better put the name everywhere
so if it does show people are like oh
[ __ ] better be a nike like a nike swoosh
where people know something no there's
nothing that makes it unless you take it
off of her and then you see it or
something but there's no real
recognition or wow six hundred dollars
for a bra yeah that bra better give me
double d's or something
yeah
if it's not doing that for 600 bucks
hell this is 550 this one is 650.
oh my god this one's 1990
what is it is this a robe is it a lacy a
lacy robe
wow
yeah what the [ __ ] that's crazy
yeah
two thousand dollars nah i'm good yeah
i'm too much wow
i buy costco underwear and i love it
they are pretty nice
good [ __ ] costco is great it comes in a
pack of five thousand
um okay uh what are some things that
you've never bought and will never buy
la perla the pearl is up there
i don't think i will ever buy a lambo
really no cut it i don't think i can go
away jose i like to drive fast i used to
oh now you're just i know is it because
there's another brand that you like
that's in that same like category no
it's because i don't want people looking
at me driving i feel like if i'm in a
lambo yeah and i pull up to a light
okay i'm always i'm always gonna be
thinking like someone's gonna be like
you better go fast in that and then i'd
be like i better go fast i better go
fast and i i've seen this video
of this person in a lambo take off and
then they just like it just goes
straight into the the uh the light bulb
oh my god and it's just it seems like a
something that would only happen in a
cartoon yeah and like the most extreme
like it could never happen but i feel
like me and a lambo would be constantly
that where i'd just be like all right
we're going to go in a straight line and
i would just like freaking out
yeah it's the pressure of driving a
lambo i would never want that wow oh
that's crazy because there's so much
open road here that i would love to have
like a sports car what would i never buy
because like right outside of summerlin
it's that red rock area uh-huh and it's
just open road it's nothing so you can
just go
you know
i'd sit passenger you know that takes
off all the pressure i'll just sit there
and be like wow it's a fast car how cute
well she's knitting yeah um damn i don't
know what i would never buy i would buy
everything
would i never buy you yeah
i don't know i'll probably never buy
like a designer bag anymore oh cause you
kind of got out of here i don't care for
it like i don't i i understand the draw
and i understand that there's like high
quality materials being used
um
but i don't
maybe that maybe just like is it like
yeah people buy birkins yeah i don't
think i don't buy much
already
but
i can see why i would buy everything
if i had a purchase you can help us see
why you would buy it remember i told you
like so if i won the lottery right
and like let's say i had nine figures or
a billion dollars like i would buy
a 747 and then tar and feather it and
make it look a bald eagle
and fly through the air right like i i
could see i could see a purpose for
literally anything for my enjoyment
so i can buy
anything like there's not a single thing
that like i've never judged anyone for
buying anything
because i'm like oh i could see what you
could get out of that
you know yeah
wow you're so positive like when me uh
when me and joe first started um
making like
like i guess like legit money one of the
first things me and joe bot were [ __ ]
these katanas
and then when i got him and remember i
got which were the katanas i don't know
it was like 200 bucks we got i was so
happy and we i got the night i needed to
make legit money to spend 200 bucks
without thinking about it
or just things you wanted to get as a
kid got it so i bought it it came at the
box at night and then the box that it
came because it's a uh it's made by this
company called uh cold steel which they
make actual like utility knives so it's
not a um
it's not like an exhibition piece mm-hmm
you know like the video that convinced
me oh no one cutting the [ __ ] big-ass
pigs yeah he had like a pork a piece of
giant pork rib and he sliced through it
and me and joe looked at each other like
holy [ __ ] you just see that
so we ordered it the night it came in
these are dumb and dumber i took the box
that it came in i put it because it was
it was like at night right i was under a
street light and i was just [ __ ]
whacking away by myself and i had so
much fun isn't that when we started um
getting cans like like we would throw a
can at you and then like i think we did
a watermelon we did a coke can yeah yeah
yeah yeah water we did a
shaving cream yeah i just [ __ ] like
talking shaving cream yeah and then it
just went
like an actual kitkat oh that's cool i
like how i talk [ __ ] but i'm like right
there with him like yeah by it yeah yeah
yeah so i would like text joe i'm like
did you get what i got yesterday yup are
we bringing the jk news yep and for
lunchtime they're just whacking [ __ ]
yeah that's awesome
i love that your your first big purchase
like that from from like your success
was
good my first one was after i got a um
my first company check it for ballet and
i used my entire week's um
uh pay for louis vuitton shoes
and like
i went there i got louis vuitton shoes
you have to did it make you feel good
though you have to it [ __ ] made me
feel like [ __ ] oh
i got shoes for whatever reason that
were too small oh no
for what for whatever reason so they
didn't fit there were these high heels
that
i mean they're high heels so it's like
you you have pretty
limited times that you wear them right
and when you do you're like oh i got to
get these off now and so like they sat
in a box just like mint condition
a because they were uncomfortable and b
because i couldn't wear them because
they were the wrong size for years and
that was just kind of like
it was just on a shelf and it became a
reminder of what i did with my money how
much
i think there were like 400 dollars how
for louis where is this that sounds like
a bargain does it four hundred dollars i
think so yeah
yeah because it was like my my like
months pay or like uh like two weeks pay
at that time wow yeah do you still have
them they're still in my parents house
you're like
wrong decision i remember never yeah you
should frame them and go don't do this
again maybe i mean i should like mimify
it at this point because it made me very
like
um just think about how i'm spending
money since that since that moment yeah
so yeah good lesson learned man
yeah okay uh what's the strangest gift
you've ever received
a golden mouse
oh my god i was there for this i have
two of them actually okay this mouse
please describe this [ __ ] thing
tamari please so which one the smaller
one or the bigger big one no one gives a
[ __ ] about the small one the small one
makes more sense than this one
so my dad
um he likes to buy things that
he thinks adds value to my life
and so
i don't even remember what it's for if
it was for christmas or my it was
probably for my birthday so i was born
in the year of the rat
and so from with me
oh yeah yeah 84 right yeah so my my dad
wanted to buy me something that he felt
like
would add value and like gold has value
and then so he bought me
this
gold rat
that's like but it looks like mickey
mouse like he's like a cartoon face and
he's holding this chinese scroll
and my dad's like this is so valuable
like make sure you take care of it
and i'm like i don't know who finds is
valuable who would want a golden cartoon
looking mouse it looks like mickey mouse
and it's like this big you might still
have it i have it you can't you can't
let go of it no and like oh we have to
display it now i have it so i have it in
a safe because it's expensive because
it's really gold
and my dad's like when you get your
forever home that's when you display it
and i'm like i don't think it's gonna
get the appreciation that you think is
gonna get but now it has to because it
doesn't look like modern art like if it
was a modern art gold thing you're like
oh that thing's kind of sick uh-huh it's
a
literally like a cartoon mouse holding a
chinese squirrel it's so interesting
it's somewhere in the middle right like
if it looked more
sculpture-like or like an ancient right
like then it could be that or it could
be modern but if it's somewhere in the
middle of the two you're just like what
is this it looks so comical
that you're like oh it's spray-painted
gold but no it's really gold yeah i wish
i was there when your dad was like
deciding you know what i mean like when
maybe there was like an array of
different
mice and he's like
that one
that's my son
yeah and it's i hope it was gold gold i
hope it was that way because he probably
he had no choice either maybe it was
just that one and it's the most it's the
most expensive useless [ __ ] because you
can't really display it because you're
not gonna get like the street cred you
think you're gonna get
and at the same time you also don't want
to get it stolen because it's a lot of
money i don't think anyone would steal
it because i don't think anyone would
think it's real it looks really if
someone broke in and they saw a golden
statue like this tall they wouldn't go
like oh [ __ ] i need to i think it's it's
in the way that it's displayed like if
it was like in like a like a glass you
know like thing yeah then they'd be like
oh that must be valuable but if it was
like on a shelf with like i don't know
like a piggy bank and like like other
things that were just like oh that must
be like something that you got i like it
at a discount disneyland point then then
you know yeah they wouldn't see that as
valuable
but i know that it's valuable and i
think that scares me you know oh i see
like if i look at the window and i'm
like oh [ __ ] you could see the piece of
gold thing from the window holy [ __ ]
yeah put it in texas room have you
received anything strange
i can't think of anything that's that's
like off the wall strange
i i think like uh
like i received a painting of myself one
time like at vidcon that sounds cool
yeah oh
i mean it was like you know it was a
what do i do with a painting of myself
you know those are rad i love those
whenever i get those i'm just like whoa
that's just we have one that they did of
one of our family photos that it was
just sent to us and it's massive it's
like 20 by 20 or something oh that's
cool let's just say this drawing was
like i looked at it i was like oh is
that what i look like
where was your eye were they both next
to each other or were they like
i mean it was just the the proportions
were kind of all over the place
oh is that it made me look at the mirror
and be like is this what my face does
look like
and it made me question what my what my
face might look like and so i was like
this is a good um
like a like a base check for myself got
it yeah yeah you're like you thought you
were hot but this is what you look like
let's just tone it down yeah no i think
it's still at my parents house though
because it's just too big to like oh
it's a big one yeah oh [ __ ] they like
[ __ ] walked with it and you had to
walk out with it yes
i'd be like this is me
cause if you got a bunch of them that'd
be cool too like a bunch of ugly
paintings of yourself
i wish can everyone see you know what
pictures i just i like how you see life
you see you see things and you're like
let's make something of it which is
really
it's great it is i'm gonna i'm gonna
display my louis vuitton shoes and my
painting please i mean you're never
gonna have that again that's true um for
me
it was an assistant manager gave me
underwear one time and it was like guy
or girl
lady oh okay uh we weren't that close
yeah that's i'm answering the question
yeah um we weren't that close i was even
surprised she gave me a gift like that's
how not close we were it's for birthday
christmas or christmas um so yeah and it
was a pack of
three underwear and it was like those
like frilly like like little girl
looking underwears like those big like
those you know what i'm talking about
did uh did other people get the same
gift i don't know i think i was just so
embarrassed to receive that that i
didn't i
i just didn't want to talk about it i
don't even know why i was so embarrassed
it's not like i gifted it to me but i
was just so embarrassed for her because
it was just so weird i think she watched
your message
no she didn't or maybe she just was like
i gotta give her something and my
daughter was gifted no i think it was
maybe you had like a period day you
didn't know and you had like a big blood
stain on your sleeve that's every girl's
[ __ ] nightmare so it can't happen she
was like
there you go i know you need these
no it wasn't even christmas time it was
like july he was like
yeah no that's what i got and i was like
and it didn't even fit did she watch you
open it no she just gifted it to me and
of course i was like oh thank you so
much and it's not even for you then if
it doesn't fit yeah what if it was a
swap
i hope so but it was it stuck with me
i'm like why did i get cause for another
chick she might have been like why the
[ __ ] are these giant panties
i don't wear giant panties dude well if
it doesn't fit you then the other ones
must be big for them
hey i'm a medium okay
how about [ __ ] double xl
i know i'm a large girl you're a large
woman i am a large woman okay but i
don't i don't wear that yeah enlarged
woman whatever okay last one
um
oh
what was the most uncomfortable thing
you've had to do out of politeness oh my
god yeah
is how long do we have yeah no we got
enough time this is the last one i think
girls are more polite
you've done [ __ ] out of politeness now
i think i could be more polite
okay mine was recent
there's so many yeah i have a lot of
these but this is the most recent one i
can think of um i went to ups i was
gonna mail out a bunch of christmas
presents and the girl that was helping
me
um i don't even know how we started
talking about this but she started
telling me about how she walked on the
soundstage of um
oh god it wasn't friends it was maybe
how i met your mother or like a sitcom
like that
and i was like oh wow that's really cool
right because i'm being respectful and
polite
and i'm like on a time crunch and i need
her to do my transaction and there's a
[ __ ] line and then she keeps talking
about how she was like touching
everything and she was so excited she
was like can't believe it me i was like
doing this and i'm like oh that is so
cool yeah um and then like i just felt
obligated to ask follow-up questions
so then like she kept going into more
and more detail and i was like [ __ ] i
can't stop because i don't want her to
feel like i'm not
giving her like like i don't know like i
don't politeness or
space or something um just reciprocating
her story yeah i just didn't want her to
feel like i'm just leaving her hanging
and i couldn't find that space to like
cut it off because she's just such a
weird character that they just keep
rambling on and she just kept hyping
herself up so like her energy just kept
growing and growing and growing and i'm
like [ __ ] i can't just go okay later you
know what i mean because you're just
like peak excitement yeah and i think i
talked to her for like 15-20 minutes oh
no way that's a long time it was and i
was like like i was trying to find any
window to cut out and it could not what
are the other customers in line going
hurry well there was two other cashiers
helping people so the line like ended
and i was looking like i was trying to
see if like their co-worker would like
come in and kind of just be like hey you
gotta get back to work and no one was
[ __ ] rescuing me and i'm like [ __ ]
what do i do i don't wanna be rude to
this [ __ ] cuz she already looks like
she's weird so i didn't want her to feel
like people were gonna go yeah i pooped
my pants and they just run away but then
i frequent this one because i have a
peel box there
so it's one of those words
yeah so i just i didn't know but then if
you establish that kind of relationship
every time you go there she's gonna
expect yeah she's gonna have a story
every time but now she knows i'm nice so
then i could be like yo i would love to
hear it tell me about it next time and i
could cut out we can only see that one
time
[ __ ] i gotta change my p.o box
[Laughter]
which is another weird thing that you
have to do to be polite
yeah exactly that's true
and i just feel bad because i know
people like i see her and i'm sure
people don't respect her like she's like
that type of character so i just didn't
want to be another person that makes her
feel like [ __ ] yeah and this is me also
probably assuming imagine everyone
[ __ ] loves her and it's just me
yeah that's my thing or what if she
feels like she's like oh whenever geo
comes in she she really wants to talk to
her imagine i know i'm bugging her yeah
she's like i always have to feel like i
have to talk to her i always have to
give her a story
that could easily happen now i'm she's
probably talking about me right now such
a weird situation so human though man
um
uh
it was a moment where i was talking to
somebody um
and it was in like a
it was at the esports arena in vegas and
so it's like dark and dingy in there and
there's like lights
i was talking to somebody who's a little
bit taller than i am um and and you know
it's like there's music going so they're
talking loud and i distinctly remember
like like engaging in the conversation
just listening and then just
feeling a spit oh no come on to my
tongue oh my god i just felt like a spit
on my tongue because i was like mid like
oh yeah
i felt it and then i just kept smiling
and kept
on
listening and i'm like what do i do
because if i close my mouth then
then the spit bubble it it congeals with
the rest of my mouth
that now i have a little bit of this
man's um spitting i didn't know the
person much either
yeah
and so i just remember just listening
and then in my mind screaming and it's
different it's different like having
someone that you know
yeah spit on you versus a stranger and i
had i had just started talking to this
person did you see him drinking coffee
on the side too oh my gosh it's just
like
it's like being vomited on by like a
friend who's who you've like been
partying with all night versus like a
complete stranger where it's just like i
don't know where this person's been i
don't know what this person does i don't
know if they brush your teeth every day
yeah i don't know that but like with a
friend i'm like ah it's a friend you
know like i i know enough and i and i
love this person enough that it's like
it's a part of their body that's on me
yeah but with a stranger
what did you do i just kept on smiling
again i just kept having a good day
oh my god
because i can't catholic right i can't
cat lick in the middle of the
conversation and i can't be like yeah
it's bad on me so
excuse me
what if you go like excuse me
yeah onto the on to the floor yeah like
i'm sorry just i do that sometimes i
pretend like you
sneeze but like i can't even close the
mouth right because it's just on the
surface of the tongue so all i could do
is probably scratch oh god yeah i can't
lick it off but like even to do that i
can't say like excuse me i'd be i'd be
like
oh that's unfortunate dude
yeah you don't have anything mine's the
opposite you spit on people no
oh you're the guy i was talking to
no mine was like one time we're on a
flight and geo fell asleep on my lap and
i don't know why but i had like crazy
like bubble guts or whatever
and then i just needed to keep farting
and i probably should have woke her up
or something but i was just like oh
she's asleep she doesn't know let's just
keep farting and i was like i probably
farted for like two three hours straight
i just kept farting and farting oh my
god
you're gonna give it her pink garden her
face is right there and then
she woke up and she goes oh my god did
you smell that
and then i don't know if i admitted it
right off the spot no you didn't i
didn't i remember i was like oh what are
you talking about
i remember this now because at that time
no system around her there was an old
man that walked by to the bathroom
because unfortunately right by the
bathroom and i remember dogging that
grandpa going you [ __ ] sick bastard
like how dare you [ __ ] spray people
with your [ __ ] nasty stench [ __ ]
and i was and i remember judging him
when he walked down and then he walked
back and it wasn't until
after the flight that he tells me he did
that and i was like this poor old man i
wished [ __ ] death on him because it
was so disturbing like the smell was
just so bad
and i'm just like oh man i hope her this
doesn't like
change her dreams or i don't know
oh my goodness yes
well well
on that now i assume she was sleeping so
i just kept pushing
oh my god you're an [ __ ] you kept it
warm around here i'm sure the climate
was completely different you know
speaking of all the bacteria and all
over our bodies you know you can't
create all that no you can't flip it as
a nice thing that he did for me you guys
will not [ __ ] allow it because cabin
pressure
bubbles get it it just doesn't you just
got to push it out i get it but you
should have woken me up and we're we
really considered divorce but you look
so peaceful too you're an [ __ ] what's
more important sleep
deep breath
yeah like
and me wishing death on this poor old
guy going like you [ __ ] animals i'm
sure he walked by and be like
did you hear me fart this morning we
were sleeping no oh okay
do you still go where you go
no cause i was in trouble because i was
sleeping on my side he doesn't care and
it was getting to the hour where we
generally are about to wake up because
our kid wakes up like six so it's like
around about 5 30 6. and then i was like
okay i'm like this is probably gonna be
silent and i pushed and it wasn't at all
and i'm like i hate you
anyway on that note mari thank you so
much this is a lot of fun
this was
i can't wait to talk about taking off my
head i can't wait i can't wait to take
that answer um yeah this is a lot of fun
thanks for having me yeah uh and thank
you guys so much and we'll catch you
guys next week bye